it is such an honor to talk to both of
you
really i didn't even get to talk to you
about dancing with princess diana phil
was that fun yeah
he danced with her my dancing partner
yeah i never had so many pictures taken
of me
as when i was dancing with princess
diana
it was fun did you happen to watch the
harry and megan
interview i feel so sorry for the queen
that poor woman what she's been through
trying to keep
that family up i mean every time she
turns around
wham you know something else has gone
wrong prince andrew
prince charles and camilla and diana
dying and i mean
i i really feel for her i i i
feel phil said he just wished he had the
interview i felt
very jealous of oprah i mean that
that's the kind of interview i would
have loved to have had i bet you would
too right drew
of course absolutely because there are
so many eyes on these two humans but
they are
two humans um and when you
talk about the royals there is a
precedence
um of behavior and a lifestyle
that may not be human in our modern
times
and so it's a very vital
and overwhelmingly interesting
discussion and oprah attributes so much
of her career to the
road that you paved phil donahue because
of the fact that you did open up the
ability to have these conversations with
people
well she's been very very generous
to me and uh
you know we're we're pals i hope they
make it i really do
i always cry at weddings because i think
they're so full of hope
you know and you hope that every married
couple
has the privacy with which to nurture
their relationship when phil and i first
got married and we did it
so that nobody knew about it until we
got out of the country for our honeymoon
and when we got back we were asked to
co-host the emmys together to co-host
the people's choice to be on the cover
of people magazine
and it was a little bit overwhelming and
we looked at each other and said let's
not do this
let's try to if we stay out of it maybe
people will leave us alone
you know if we don't throw it out there
and so we decided
we won't do that we won't do interviews
about our marriage we won't
co-host anything we'll just lay back and
try to have our privacy
so that we can find out who we are as a
couple
and when i first had the idea to do the
book and the podcast
phil said i'll go with you but i'm not
talking about our marriage
but once we got on these double dates
and people talked about
their jealousy mark consuelos was
married to kelly ripa talked about
his jealousy so phil talked about his
jealousy
they talked about fighting we talked
about fighting we talked about spending
money
so whatever they talked about we talked
about it was a real double date
and it was fun it was and i learned
stuff about phil and he learned stuff
about me
and and we learned how to work together
we have never worked together because we
were always afraid we'd kill each other
because we're both type a personalities
and we're both kind of bossy
and so we thought we wouldn't make it
but after 40 years we did it
yeah after 40 years here we are
and uh you know once in a while i get to
say a few things
[Laughter]
i don't i don't want to bore you
quite the opposite i'm glad that you
made the choices that you did and i
understand
myself it's i was speaking to howard
stern about it the other day and i said
having that like new couple alert in
hollywood probably feels the same as an
inner office romance or a high school
crush
it's all relative in the emotions and
the feelings and
you do want to protect and it is scary
to have
other people all of a sudden ascend on
your sacred
private thing and choosing to put it out
there
is a certain act of bravery but then you
have to be prepared for what comes with
that
and it is difficult to navigate any
relationship
right you need the privacy thank you
phil
and marlo for coming here when this show
was in its inception
i was hoping to speak with both of you
for so many reasons
and thank you you're sure you're so
sweet you're a very very sweet woman
thank you thank you very generous and we
love being with you and
we look forward to being with you when
the cameras aren't rolling you're a
pleasure
i think i've actually said to you marlo
i think i was bold enough to say i would
love to come to one of your dinner
parties and you have an amazing
collaboration with pottery barn and
william sonoma
with your beautiful collection and
please go on marla's social media
and look at these retailers to see her
gorgeous tablescape
prowess and her history with it and
thank you so much
and let this be the continuation
of um a relationship that is built
on nothing but respect thank you
[Music]